hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt's eine kleine erzählstunde
ich empfehle euch nämlich mal was wir
lassen heute mal die katze aus dem sack
mit muss sagen oder
ja wir haben schon vor ein paar wochen
auf facebook und auf instagram ein
kleines posting gemacht von der
baustelle sei die auf der baustelle
und natürlich haben sich viele zu recht
gefragt ja ausbauen denn die fällige
rate und ich habe auch euch gefragt was
glaubt ihr denn was wir hier gerade
bauen ja viele haben ihr tipp morath auf
einem chip fabrik klassische von promis
steuerlich oft da hat er leider keine
qualifikation dafür er kann zu zweit
aber nicht herstellen
ein anderes thema da nahm einige
vermuteten kinderheim vielleicht also es
war wirklich sehr ehrenhaft war
wunderschön aber da bedarf ein bisschen
mehr als nur als ein bauplatz und steine
deswegen erzählen wir euch heute dass
wir unser haus bauen umbauen
wir bauen das ist voll schön ich bin
jetzt 28 jahre alt morath bisschen älter
35 jetzt ja jetzt bauen wir und wir
möchten euch heute im video man erzählen
warum hört bauen
warum es sich vielleicht auch lohnt zu
bauen vielleicht auch nicht lohnt zu
bauen
und wo wir bauen also bei uns ist es so
ich bin in einer siebenköpfigen familie
aufgewachsen ich habe also vier
geschwister meine eltern sind da und ich
liebe es mit meiner familie zu sein
ich bin einfach ein familienmensch murat
hat auch fünf geschwister hat ein
geschwisterchen mehr als ich und wir
sind einfach beide in der großfamilie
aufgewachsen und ich habe eben bis ich
mit murat geheiratet habe auch zu hause
gewohnt bei meiner familie bei meinen
eltern und mit meinen geschwistern und
ich finde es einfach wunderschön wenn
man einfach zusammen aufwachsen kann und
bei mir war es schon immer mal ein
wunsch und ein traum dass ich einfach
irgendwann dann heirate kinder bekomme
und irgendwann mit meinen eltern
zusammen wohnen so wichtig ein mama und
papa kind genau das so riecht und strebe
reich so bauer vertrag mit den eltern
aber ich merke einfach auf meinen
kindern tut es gut meinen eltern tut uns
auch gut wissen halt wirklich ständig
zusammen und deswegen möchten wir auch
gerne mit meinen eltern zusammen wohnen
haben uns eben dazu entschlossen zu
bauen momentan ist bei uns die situation
so machen und nicht wir leben schon in
unserer dritten gemeinsamen wohnung
gehört auch im hintergrund die kinder
sind auch gerade da und zwar haben wir
am anfang in der zwei zimmer wohnung
gewohnt und zwar war das die wohnung in
der ich aufgewachsen bin also wird die
wohnung meiner eltern
danach sind wir umgezogen weil samira
auf die welt kam ich habe studiert
morath studiert und wir brauchten
einfach im kinderzimmer denn die
zweizimmerwohnung hatte gar kein
kinderzimmer und sind in eine drei
zimmer wohnung umgezogen und diese
wohnung wurde dann auch zu kleinen da
war die küche zu klein und wir haben uns
dazu entschlossen mensch youtube soll
bei uns ein bisschen mehr werden wir
brauchen eine größere küche also sind
wir in diese wohnung gezogen und diese
wohnung hier ist nicht klein die hat
etwa 100 und s 10 umsatz 20 13
quadratmeter wohnfläche
hallo hallo aladag telefoniert sie hat
etwa 110 quadratmeter wohnfläche
wir haben ein kinderzimmer wir haben es
hier echt groß also wohnzimmer ist es
ziemlich groß aber das ganze problem bei
der sache ist nicht das eine
kinderzimmer denn ich finde kinder
können auch zusammen in einem
kinderzimmer groß werden
wenn ich überlege ich mit meinen fünf
geschwister mit meinen eltern ich habe
in einer zwei zimmer wohnung gelebt dann
auch keine hobbys co aber man kann hat
auch situation früher nicht mit der
situation heute vergleichen also heute
ist einfach so ich habe zum beispiel
meine hausaufgaben im wohnzimmer machen
müssen während meine eltern noch bis so
hatten
ich habe im wohnzimmer auch geschlafen
hinterm sofa hatte ich so eine kleine
luftmatratze auf dem boden und es war
bissig tatsächlich 15 war mein
kinderzimmer 350 mal so auch noch echt
unglaublich und erst mit 15 hatte ich
dann ein kinderzimmer mit meinem bruder
zusammen und ja das war so und drei
jahre später habe ich geheiratet
die chancen dazu
ausgezogen sein bruder zusammen das
geheim wahnsinn wahnsinn oder
ja ich ja jeden fall das kann man
einfach nicht mehr mit heute vergleichen
heute ist einfach so die kinder brauchen
ihren rückzugsort die müssen ihre
hausaufgaben in ruhe machen können
die müssen in ruhe lernen können auch
mal abschalten können und das geht bei
uns hier einfach nicht denn ihr selbst
auch schon hier alles passiert hier um
uns herum denn wir arbeiten eben auch
von unserer wohnung aus das heißt von
montags bis freitags wird bei uns in der
küche gefilmt ich drehe videos ich backe
und koche sanierer macht natürlich mega
viel spaß da auch mitzumachen
aber es gibt einfach ein tag wo sie sagt
auch ich hab ich jetzt aber keine lust
zu backen ich will lieber was mal oder
mit meiner freundin spielen und dann ist
halt immer ein bisschen problematisch
bei uns zu hause weil einfach alles
voller kameras steht überall stehen
lichter überall hängen kabel auf dem
boden herum und gerade für die ella ist
es zb eine ziemlich große gefahrenquelle
also jetzt mal abgesehen davon dass
unser haushalt zwar schon relativ kinder
sicher ist aber wenn wir dann eben
filmen und die kameras aufgebaut haben
ist einfach gar nichts mehr sicher also
wir müssen ständig aufpassen dass sie
nicht über irgendwelche kabel stolpern
dann kommen irgendwelche lieferungen
dann klettert sie auf die kartons hoch
und tanzte auf den kartons herum tanzten
auf den tischen herum und lustig aber es
ist einfach so wir können halt nicht
fertig drehen also wir stehen dann
abends und 17.30 noch da und das video
dann noch nicht fertig weil einfach zu
viel im alltag passiert und man kann
auch gar nicht richtig abschalten ja du
bist dann abends fertig kann die kameras
nicht weg kommen am nächsten tag wieder
tränen tust oder müsste offen wo im
wohnzimmer und alle sterne haben die
ganzen kameras herum
das heißt wenn wir abends ausmachen die
lichter hier hinter uns ausmachen und
denken okay setzen wir uns mal hin und
holen uns mal aus dann sitzt du im
prinzip da und denkst steht da bricht
und da endlich da hängt noch das kabel
man kann gar nicht richtig abschalten
und deswegen ist für uns schon ziemlich
großes problem momentan von zu hause aus
zu arbeiten und wir haben einfach kein
ausweichraum das heißt wir haben nicht
mal ein büro wo wir dann die sachen
unterbringen könnten also unser
equipment man kann schon sagen oder
gästeklasse auch alles im wohnzimmer
machen die seehasen wohnzimmer genau die
ganzen fotos stehen hier von mir als
schreibtisch wird immer als foto
tischbein umfunktioniert und es ist
einfach dementsprechend sehr voll
dann sind wir auch beim dreh nicht
alleine das heißt wir haben mindestens
zwei kameraleute mit dabei manchmal ich
meine mama noch mit dabei manchmal sind
noch freunde mit dabei und das ist dann
einfach sehr sehr sehr voll
jetzt einfach so genau das war halt
einer der gründe mir gesagt haben genau
es muss irgendwann was muss passieren
wir müssen oder wir wollen auch
irgendwann was bauen und deswegen ist
jetzt für uns wirklich so der perfekte
zeitpunkt da ich muss auch das zu sagen
ich bin noch in meinem zeitplan drin ich
habe immer gesagt ich möchte mit anfang
mitte 20 kinder bekommen
und spätestens mit ende zwanzig dreißig
möchte ich gerne was eigenes bauen und
ich bin ganz glücklich dass wir das zu
dieser zeit jetzt machen denn jetzt muss
wirklich was das sehen jetzt müssen wir
besser strukturierter werden und auch so
ein bisschen
dieses private trennen von unseren
videos also nicht nicht so dass wir
sagen es sich nicht mehr privat aber wir
müssen einfach den arbeitsplatz so ein
bisschen trennen dass es eben auch ein
bisschen sicherer wird für die kinder
und die wenig angst haben müssen dass
ich irgendwo mal und stativ auf den kopf
haut und habt ihr die kamera schon gar
nicht gegangen problem wenn die wohnung
einfach größere genau meine wohnung
größe wäre dann auch bleiben
wir haben möglich dass gäste klamm und
funktioniert als altes kamera lager die
frau hat habe ich sowieso schon voll mit
lauter rettungspaketen genau dosen und
schüsseln und töpfen und allem also ist
es schon kein normaler haushalt hier
kann man schon mal die nachbarn uns
immer fragen ob wir hier wirklich wohnen
aber wir wohnen hier
unfassbar und es ist so voll hier und es
ist echt ein schönes machen
du kannst nicht mehr strukturiert aber
ja und das ist können wir sagen ja der
erste wird dann einmal im monat sind
bürotisch und deswegen bauen während es
auch ganz dafür hätten es aber auch
natürlich nach größeren wohnungen
umgeschaut oder in einem kleinen haus zu
mieten
nur das problem ist heute heißen die
mieten so teuer
es lohnt sich schon gar nicht kenne also
da zahlst du wirklich
da muss einfach finden genau also viel
gezahlte mieten zwischen 1000 und
zweieinhalb tausend euro und es ist so
extrem viel ich weiß für manche für euch
ist es für den hamburger sagt 1000 euro
miete dieser innenstadt das ist ja gar
nix für umfeld auch schafft man wird auf
dem land bis sagen die acht gottes ist
viel zu sehen
es kommt immer auf die regionen wo wir
wohnten in so einer mittelmäßigen region
und ich finde einfach 1500 euro bis 2000
euro miete zahlen
dies ist so sehr viel lieber hey wir
bauen uns ja also wir sind einfach der
meinung mieter ist zwar gut und schön
aber man kann das geld einfach auch in
sein eigenheim investieren
die augen schließt und fotoapparat und
ich weiß hier innen immer irgendwo etwas
eingetreten habe jetzt wieder gespiegelt
und gehirn das stück hat irgendwie
e-mails wissensspiele mit mir okay also
haben wir für uns beschlossen jetzt ist
der perfekte zeitpunkt um zu bauen wir
haben vor sieben jahren zusammen zwei
bausparverträge gemacht und die sind
jetzt eben ausgelaufen sage ja genau und
jetzt im prinzip der punkt da wo wir
sagen okay man hat jetzt ein bisschen
was angespart
die zinssätze momentan sehr günstig also
ich glaube überhaupt noch nie so etwas
wirklich erinnere mich noch an die
zeiten als mein papa sein eigenheim
finanziert hat also seine hohe niveau
der hat die haben sieben bis acht
prozent zinsen gezahlt und jetzt sind
sie echt momentan zwischen ein und zwei
prozent manchmal sogar günstiger und
wenn man nicht jetzt wann dann
dann ist natürlich auch der punkt dass
wir sagen gut wir brauchen mehr platz
und eben der wichtigste grund für mich
ist ich möchte einfach mit meinen eltern
zusammen wohnen mein papa da ich 70
meine mama hat mich ja und ich möchte
einfach die zeit ich mit meinen eltern
noch haben sie war sie vollkommen mit
ihnen
man sich nicht ganz auf er ist keine
ahnung und einer mit brille und und
platze ich bin gleich nach solche
bringen ganz normale alltag bei uns beim
dreh es klingelt die kinder kommen
ella schmidt ihre rotznase auf meine
sache jetzt ist die post da gleich kommt
der mond wieder hoch meistens hat dem
rat keinen schlüssel dann klingt er
nämlich ständig naja führen telefon
klingelt ständig die post ja was für
eine überraschung
hier danke dafür jessica genug und noch
ein grund für uns zu sagen wir bauen
jetzt denn man kann ja auch was
verstehen dass schon kaufen
aber bei uns ist es einfach sehr
vorteilhaft zu bauen denn der morath
kommt ja aus der baubranche dadurch
stark und wie schnell diese steiniger
sie gelernt clara rohbau erstellt die
steine her und das heißt er kennt sich
mit der materie aus und man muss sagen
unsere familie unser freundeskreis ist
sehr groß und wir haben wirklich in
jedem bereich irgendjemanden wir haben
fensterbauer in der familie in meine
cousins und alle fans maler lackierer
architektur macht mein bruder elektriker
architektur haben als bruder also wir
haben wirklich für jeden bereich irgend
jemanden den wir kennen
es ist nicht jemand vorteil muss man
sagen dass ich trotzdem sei gut und von
daher mir wirklich immer jemanden an der
hand stellen uns einfach beim bau helfen
kann und diese nicht jeder durch kann
natürlich immer viel selber machen kann
man kosten sparen und wie ich komm
kumpel aus der baufamilie hat keiner was
lernen alle vom bauch wenn dabei ist
handwerklich mega begabt also mein papa
ist ermahnt der wirklich auf dieser welt
am meisten kann ich kenne er mehr kann
entweder macht kaputt was richtig aber
er kann sehr viel und kann sich auch
super unterstützen ja von daher ist
natürlich für uns die ideale lösung
einfach selbst zu bauen kaufen wir
einfach zu teuer wenn man die
immobilienpreise so hoch so extrem hoch
und die mieten auch und deswegen werfen
uns kaufen kann
keine option wir sind halt der mensch
wir möchten gern eigenheim möchten
selber bauen aber es gibt natürlich auch
menschen wie meine schwester zum
beispiel die möchten gar kein eigenheim
die sind total glücklich in ihrer
mietwohnung und die verreisen dann
lieber also die fliegenden jahr bestimmt
drei mal in urlaub jetzt so getan ist ja
gerade in thailand und lässt sich das
mit gehen lernt wie hier alle frieren
und für sie ist einfach wichtiger der
zeitpunkt jetzt zu leben und sie sagt
sich warum soll ich ein haus abbezahlen
oder eine wohnung ab es an wenn ich auch
einfach jetzt
man muss den kopf ab und erreichte den
bus aber typ dazu sein wie ich für 20
jahre lang im haus abzubezahlen ja auch
dinge und vor allem natürlich die
sicherheiten haben du kannst ja nicht
einfach hingehen und sagen okay ich baue
jetzt einfach und habe mir noch keine
gedanken über die kosten über die
konsequenzen gemacht und natürlich passt
bei uns auch die momentane situation wir
sind aus waake also ich bin aus
waghäusel ich bin auch hier groß
geworden
meine eltern wohnen auch noch hier und
brads arbeitsplatz ist in der nähe und
mein arbeitsplatz natürlich auch von
daher ist es für uns natürlich geschickt
hier auch in waghäusel für bleiben und
zu bauen
genau das hatte ich auch immer stimmen
genau das muss auch schon die arbeiter
aber es muss stimmen und dein papa der
ist jetzt auch schon seit fünf jahren
rentner das heißt derzeit und das
problem bei den eltern war halt einfach
dämonen in seiner gewohnheit in einem
mehrfamilienhaus weiter oben da müssen
viele treppen laufen
ich habe früher auch gewohnt aber in
jungen jahren macht es einem nicht so
viel aus aber wenn man halt irgendwann
knieschmerzen bekommt und das haben
meine eltern zum beispiel wenn alle in
der familie knie probleme und dann ist
einfach irgendwann nicht mehr so schön
wenn man eben komplett bis nach oben
laufen muss und von daher ist natürlich
super wenn wir das jetzt alles so
realisieren können genau wie es jetzt
ist es so und wir bringen die kids immer
zu den ober zu oma und opa oma die haben
uns schon immer geholfen ja also meine
eltern sind eigentlich auch der grund
warum ich das hier eigentlich alles
machen kann also die haben mich während
dem studium komplett unterstützt ich
habe samira zum beispiel während im
studium bekommen im vierten semester und
habe sie dann am anfang mit zur uni
genommen also mit zur hochschule und
dann als ebenso groß war dass sie
krabbeln konnte hat sie natürlich die
uni unsicher gemacht also habe ich sie
bei meiner mama gelassen und sie hat
auch sie aufgepasst
und die haben mich wirklich von anfang
an in alle unterstützt und haben mir
geholfen dass ich überhaupt alles so
erreichen konnte das heißt ich kann nur
so viele videos drehen weil meine eltern
eben auch da sind die wir dann eben auch
ab und zu die kinder abnehmen und mit
ihnen einfach draußen spielen zu hause
spielen und von daher möchte ich
natürlich auch dass meine eltern mich da
gerne so ein bisschen zurückgeben und
meine eltern auch zu mir holen denn ich
möchte einfach jede freie minute mit
ihnen verbringen und natürlich meine
kinder auch wir möchten euch auch später
wenn es natürlich möglich ist die eltern
pflegen wenn es geht und wenn ihre
einfach zuschauen lassen sich nicht
machen müssen ein wenig das machen
müssen aber dass die bis zum lebensende
bei uns bleiben aus weil wirklich das
wieder vergessen ganz ganz toller typ
wenn du macht zwar immer witze über die
schwiegereltern aber die sind echt
sollte gold wert das ist der wahnsinn
und ohne diät und ist alles hier nicht
geschafft und wird sein studium nicht
geschafft und darf nicht so schnell
gelegt so schnell ich hätte dann halt
eine pause einlegen müssen und ja ich
hätte alles gar nicht so schnell machen
können und gelaunt als wir noch bei
gespielt haben haben uns auch finanziell
muss man auch sagen und das möchte er
nicht zurückgeben weil ich ganz ehrlich
sein wenn ich mal älter bin möchte ich
eigentlich einmal das heim sein wenn es
wenig sinn jetzt deswegen sagt für
samira mir zu ich pass auf dich auf habe
ich erstmal nicht beim auto gesagt und
wenn ich mal später älter werde der
bucht auf mich aufpassen
und ja natürlich fertig sein und es ist
unsere generation raus ist immer schön
und es ist auch einer der hauptgründe
dass ich einfach mit den eltern
schwiegereltern zusammen sein möchte
vielleicht meine mutter ja auch mal
dessen einer dieser vielen gründe warum
ihr einfach sagen komm lass uns was
zusammen machen mit den eltern zusammen
das sind platz haben für die kinder
genau ich möchte tiere haben
ich möchte eine ziege haben ich
verspreche dir nur mal gucken vielleicht
schaffen wir das ja ja deswegen der bau
und haben uns überlegt dass wir euch so
ein bisschen auch mitnehmen und
vielleicht auch ein paar tipps und
tricks zeigen können wie man vielleicht
auch etwas günstiger bauen kann wo man
geld sparen kann weil man vielleicht
planungsfehler vermeidet also der firma
rostock was falsch wir sind ja schon im
besitz
im rohbau wir haben schon ein paar
fehler gemacht die haben uns sehr viel
geld gekostet
und weshalb man viel überlegen
vielleicht zwei drei kleine ein paar
kleine kann ja mal passieren auch ich
habe übrigens auch lustig sein wo ja
naja kann passieren genau wenn der
eigene bruder ist kann man halt genau
dass seine mutter geflucht spaß
natürlich natürlich
natürlich ist nur spaß man macht auch
viele fehler im bau ist ganz normal
ja aber im bau kann sowas auch
verheerend sein wie man will
wo ist sein kredit bei der bank und sagt
auch ich soundso wir brauchen um in das
ding jetzt plötzlich das level der
mehrkosten leben richtiges problem ein
bisschen macht fehler haben wir machen
wir auch unia prozent aber die kann man
eben auch vermeiden zum teil und da
denke ich können wir euch vielleicht ein
paar nützliche tipps und tricks geben
auch grad so welche steine man nimmt
welche materialien verarbeitet und da
schalte murat echte perfekte
ansprechperson am schluss sagen
und das heißt wir nehmen euch ein paar
mal mit auf dem bau wird immer samstags
sein das heißt die videos kommen dann
immer samstags um euch zeigen wie wir
was machen
vielleicht macht es anders ich habe
andere gegebenheiten er bei jedem ist es
anders und deswegen hoffe aber dass wir
dann vielleicht zuschauen möchte
vielleicht bekommen wir ein paar tipps
genau vielleicht bekommen wir auch ein
paar tipps von euch was man machen
könnte und er kommt ja auch alle helfen
zum schaufeln zum zu mauern mit fug und
sie möchten wirklich so viel als möglich
selber machen oder hohenstadt nicht
können kommen halt einfach gern
fachleute lohn aus den jahren helfen
freunde die uns helfen
das schaffen wir schon das kriegen wir
schon gebacken wie wir jetzt wissen
bescheid wir bauen kleines häuschen mit
den genauen mit dem coolen küchenstudio
wir später auch mal zuschauen ein
hinzu sollen genau also damit meine
küche dann einfach nur ein bisschen
optimiert das heißt ich habe zwar hier
echt eine tolle küche aber ich hab ich
auch damals immer im küchen video ein
paar planungsfehler damals schon gezeigt
man lernt ja wirklich jedes mal was
neues
und jedes mal lernen aus seinen fehlern
und dieses mal denke ich habe ich
einfach die perfekte basis um zu sagen
okay diese küche war gut aber ich kann
sie natürlich noch optimieren ich kann
den einen oder anderen fehler vermeiden
eine herdplatte zb so wie es am anfang
befürchtet hatte habe ich ja gesagt ich
möchte sie nicht so oben liegend haben
ohne rand weil ich einfach befürchtet
dass sie irgendwann reißt und springt
und genau das ist passiert an drei
stellen ist sicher kaputt und es ist
natürlich ziemlich ärgerlich wenn man so
was am anfang schon im hinterkopf hat
und der küchenplaner dann sagten die
nähe alles gut alles gut
und deswegen denke ich habe dieses mal
einfach schon eine gute beratung und ich
sind da jetzt schon an der planung an
dem ist euch forschen wir sind beim
rohbau müssen aber jetzt schon überlegen
wie die küche aussehen soll wo es soll
der härchen wo die spiele wegen dem
abwasser also man muss sich im prinzip
gratis geistig schon im haus drin sehen
und wissen da ist es das fenster das und
die spüle hin da hinten vielleicht kein
fenster dass ich platz vier hoch streng
gehabt und es sind einfach so sachen die
uns gerade beschäftigen und wo wir
wirklich viel viel zeit auf breiten
investieren müssen
aber ich denke wenn man sich jetzt die
zeit nimmt bei der planung hat man
später einfach was schönes und genau das
heißt wir werden dann auch in die küche
um planung mit einbezogen
ihr seht wie wenig wie geplant dann
natürlich wie mein haus plant natürlich
was kann man machen kurze wege zu haben
dann auch sicherheit im haus auch gerade
einen eindruck zahlen momentan ganz
vitaminreich und ein sicheres haus da
man aber auch sagen wir mal zu viel geld
auszugeben hat es da kann wenn man sich
da wirklich gut informiert kann man
wirklich gut und preiswert ein sicheres
haus bauen und dann geht sie sich auch
uhr umwelt sachen zum beispiel dass man
wir haben ergebnis mit einer komplett
auf gas verzichtet auf den haben auch
komplett verzichtet auf brennstoffe
nicht ganz stimmt nicht mehr
wir haben
wärmepumpe kombination zwischen
wärmepumpe aber auch holz also ganz ganz
ding wie sehr interessant erzählt es
kommt dann zu geeigneter zeit und ich
würde vorschlagen dass er jetzt gerne in
die kommentare schreiben könnt falls
euch etwas brennend interessiert falls
ihr fragen habt oder auch schon tipps
dann kümmert dass er jetzt so im laufe
unserer bei videos verbissen mit
einplanen
genau wie willst du noch eingehen genau
was wir vielleicht wissen was für dich
interessieren vielleicht ob gebaut ich
weiß viele von euch kam schon gebaut und
ihr wisst schon wie stressiges sein
ihr seht ihr studium fertig immer das
kind auf die welt gebracht noch ein kind
auf die welt gebracht
er hat zwischenzeitlich noch als funky
ich noch zwischenzeitlich und jetzt
kommt der bau also genau so leben wie es
ein er stattfindet heirat kinder nadal
hopper während dem ganzen also während
dem studium dann heiraten und vielleicht
dann kriegt man kinder baut irgendwann
mathaf währenddessen aber nicht
vergessen auch im moment jetzt zu leben
muss man dazu sagen so stressig es auch
schon auch ist man muss sich jeden tag
zeit nehmen für sich und seine frau sind
was das leben wirklich an ihr vorbei und
dafür kommt einfach nichts mit weil
manchmal ist man echt abends 18 830 bin
fix und fertig und denkt auch eingeführt
jetzt am liebsten ins bett gehe
aber dann nehme ich mir noch die zeit
und spielhaus mit samira auf ihrem
teppich oder raus das muss man auch
wirklich machen denn sonst das leben an
dir vorbei und ich höre schon wieder die
ja deswegen natürlich geht's mit dem
zweier aus denn die beiden sind leider
ein bisschen erkälteten samira konnten
kindergarten
also müssen als bislang die frische luft
ja wo ich glaube werden jetzt alles
gesagt oder genau wie man uns an die
planung findest du musst doch gemütlich
hier ist somit euch zu reden ist das
truck komisch für mich meinen dann so in
dieser kamera zu gucken aber ich stelle
mir schon vor wie er vor den laptop
sitzend oder vom handy und dazu hört ich
glaube auch dass viele ist momentan
denke ich ja bei den reisen momentan
also bei den zinsen
ja und wenn man abbauen möchte sollte
genau wie connections hat zu
baustoffhändler käme heute die usa
verpasst aber morath ja gut los arbeit
hochschwarzwald
oder arbeit sein und ich habe genau noch
oft bei dir also bis zum nächsten mal
angeln schreibt uns gern eure fragen und
eure eure fragen und eure tipps genau
was unsere was essen wir gehen noch auf
die baumesse ja genau wir gehen noch auf
die baumesse und zwar am 21
21 stimmen 21 januar sind wir auf der
baumesse in münchen
und da sind wir an dem stand aber das
teil noch rechtzeitig mit klopp stadtbus
ich weiß ich weiß beim beim stand bei
xella und werden da ja informieren
und da gibt es auch noch karten zu
verdanken genau wie gehe ich auch gerade
auf baumesse um zu wissen was ja
momentan machen also mir jetzt nur auf
torten back und haushalts weil ich jetzt
für mich privat brauche genau kinder und
auch infobox genaue rein und auch im
nächsten video von den nächsten
wichtigen dafür
man kann nämlich 200 freikarten kam es
nicht aber zwei freikarten oder auf
demnächst beim nächsten video gemacht
alles klar also freut sich schon drauf
vielleicht könnt euch den termin schon
vormerken und wir sehen uns dann ganz
bald bis zum nächsten mal tschüss